[Music]
okay everybody this is my
spoiler-free review of netflix's new
series resident evil now i am someone
who is a huge resident evil fan i have
fallen in love with these games and in
particular the most recent ones like
resident evil village and biohazard just
some great games i highly suggest if you
haven't played them before definitely
worth your time but what's great about
those games not only is that they're
scary they're thrilling but they also
have really good stories in them and
really cool characters i think what's
frustrated a lot of people about
resident evil adaptations they just
can't get the story right from the games
or they mess with the characters a
little too much and you just don't feel
that connection to it where yes when a
show or movies adapting something it's
based off like a book or a game you have
leeway you have to make it its own but
there's also this like obsession with
resident evil adaptations to not even
try to relate it to the games in any
reasonable way that makes us feel and
connect and kind of what we're signing
up for with that brand name of resident
evil on it i sadly will report that i
thought the trail looked pretty good
wanted to give this a shot open mind
and
it bizarrely continues this streak of a
very very poor resident evil adaptation
for some reason we cannot get a good
adaptation of this franchise anywhere
and
it's really crazy because
it feels like when you watch this that
if you had to think in your head how can
i piss off resident evil fans the most
what do i need to do do that this series
does that they like decide to go against
the grain in the worst way possible
because
really what it is in the day which is
going to make people really not like
this series is it's just a why a netflix
show not a great one at that i have
nothing against that genre but it's just
stamped with the resident evil name on
it so it's not going from the resident
evil lore it's not
doing that first and then sprinkling its
own flavor to it it's the opposite or
it's sprinkling in a little resident
evil but at the end of the day it's just
another netflix y show that isn't a good
one and it's really just bizarre the
decisions they make and look for the
target audience having the title of
resident evil they should be directing
it towards resident evil fans and that's
the bizarre thing about because it's
right away lets you know that they're
not going for that because it plays a
lot of hip-hop music it has a character
whose lead character named billy she
literally dresses like billy eilish and
they play a bunch of billy eilish in the
show again it feels like they're trying
to piss off resident evil fans and it
does make sense though because then you
look at the show runner who is andrew
dab who is a writer from the cw series
supernatural so
has very cw feelings like that where
it's again popular music and it has to
do with focusing on things that would
appeal more to a younger audience and
not per se to a resident evil crowd that
is usually more adult and wanting things
more serious and
having more strong horrors so it really
is just a head scratcher watching this
like i can't believe they're doing this
again that it was put in the hands of
someone who's a writer of supernatural
was probably the first mistake in
general that netflix made and there is
some stuff that you are like how did
this get past the cutting room floor i'm
not spoiling anything but there is
someone who gets infected and they have
a line it's about the second episode and
they say
should i quarantine and the character
says back
no it's not like coven and there is no
other mention of coven in this show
again it's writing like that that makes
you just
go oh my god like it's bizarre how bad
some lines are in this show and it's not
all bad i mean you'll see in the
promotional photos there's like liquors
and there's monsters you'll recognize
from resident evil they're really cool
looking you know but they're few and far
between i mean if there's anything you
can take from it if you're looking for
that kind of thing which i think we're
all signing up for just fast forward and
go to those scenes you can watch them
they're pretty sick but the rest is just
again netflix why a content and lance
riddick's lance riddick he's good but
it just feels like
why do they have all this potential
especially with netflix and doing it in
a show format that's what got me
intrigued was like okay let's see it as
a show and give time to the characters
they just don't want to make it a
credible horror show they just don't
feel like it they have to make it just
go to the lowest common denominator with
again having hit music throughout pop
music and it's just poorly poorly done
and i'm not saying that i'm trying to
make this review not sound like someone
who's wishing for something but it's
more of like no
either way if you like that genre it's
not good version of that genre it's just
not good and also it's rated m a so
you're you're wondering why they even
are targeting that where half the
audience might not be able to watch that
so just frustratingly bad this show and
i was really excited for it in a sense
because again it's resident evil so any
time like okay maybe this is the time
it's gonna hit no
i promise you people are gonna hate this
show i'm giving this one a 4.4 the
reason it's not maybe even lower is
because again you get some nice stuff
with monsters like liquors you get some
cool action here and there but that's
really all you're getting and there's
cool set pieces i'll give it that you
know so there was potential there and
again it's just really what you're
getting is resident evil stamped on a
netflix product that's not really
resident evil so this is just crazy to
me and this is just not good for netflix
because he needs something to pick up
after stranger things to keep people
hooked and talk about this isn't going
to be it at all they're going to talk
about how bad it is i promise you i
promise you so i'm sorry to say that
maybe you'll like it but i did not enjoy
this at all uh really really just
not good this is netflix at its worst
and it sucks that it's happening with a
very popular franchise and resident evil
it's a very missed opportunity in that
sense so let me know if you're going to
watch it let me know your thoughts on
other resident evil adaptations if you
plan on watching we thought the trailer
and let me know your thoughts when you
do see it please come back and comment i
want to hear one's thoughts on this one
you guys think and if you like what i do
here please follow me at steve barley
show on twitter instagram and tick tock
for more of me you can give a tip
anytime you want to help so much it's
right below or you can become a member
which helps even more and i'll see you
next time